a lot of times we think about the way
that we do business and kind of develop
countries that we're like well you know
we're going in an efficient way we'll
just jump on a call and kind of get
things done
well that's not typically how things
work in a lot of other countries in the
region you kind of need to
be sensitive to all of these nuances if
you want to actually be successful
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me how are
you i'm very good thank you
good to be here with you in dubai it's
wonderful to be here in dubai
so we have our whole new set up here you
know i've been doing this over zoom
for 250 episodes i've done one episode
in person this is my
second one and i'm honored to be with
you here in dubai thank you for joining
me
absolutely great to have you here yvonne
we're in the beautiful emirates tower i
don't think that we can really see it
here but
i'm just going to show it anyway the
incredible view of dubai
it really phenomenal place of innovation
i've been
shocked and blown away by what's
happening in this place yvonne
how did you get to dubai because you've
done stanford business school you're
originally from serbia you spent many
years in google
how do you end up helping run
investments in portfolio companies in
dubai
uh short answer by chance obviously
right
so the story is as follows uh i'm
originally from serbia
as you mentioned so i moved to the
states to do a stand for graduate school
business
uh that was back in 2006 uh after i
graduated i joined the consulting firm
and moved to the city right san
francisco and uh
back in the day my thinking was
essentially like you know kind of found
my american dream right
all that i have to do is kind of you
know have a couple of kids two and a
half kids to be more precise
what pick offense uh a dog and there i
should be all set right
except that somehow life worked out so
after a couple years
in in consulting uh in 2008 you know
there was the global financial crisis
and markets kind of started to rumble a
little bit
and the firm that i was with at the time
they were basically looking they had a
booming and thriving business here in
the middle east
they were looking for people within the
system to kind of move temporarily to
the middle east to kind of help them
essentially
deliver on all the projects that they
were able to sell
right so you know before i knew it i was
basically like you know what's
what what's the worst thing that could
possibly happen i've never been to the
middle east before right the only thing
i knew about the middle east was kind of
from six o'clock news and that was never
a good thing
for the most part right but i've been
thinking like you know it's like the
line of eternal sun uh go there go for a
couple years you know make some tax free
money repay my student loans and before
i know that i was going to be back home
right or that's at least what i what i
thought uh
that was 2008 fast forward 12 and a half
years i guess
you know life is temporary as it is but
it turned out to be a little bit more
temporary than the the original two
years uh idea
unbelievable so you joined google right
so you spend quite a long time with
with google helping them expand their
market and growth into the into middle
east north african markets
what is that like what is that
responsibility and telling what were
some of the biggest challenges that you
have you've had along that journey
yeah so one of the things that people
don't necessarily
not understand but like uh comprehend
right
is we talk about mina which is the
middle east north africa region a lot of
people kind of talk about it as kind of
a region which is relatively
uniform right in reality it's anywhere
between 19 and 21 countries depending on
the day and depending on you know who
does the content
uh which are actually very very
different right so we sit here in the
gulf in the emir to dubai which is part
of the united arab emirates
uh one of the richest countries in the
world like for all intents and purposes
actually a very very developed country
uh but another country in mina is uh uh
is egypt right more than 100 million
people but it's actually kind of more in
the range of developing countries as
opposed to kind of developed countries
and everything that kind of comes with
it by kind of from the level of
sophistication the maturity of the
markets to the level if you're talking
about digital economy
you know the penetration mobile phone
internet payment uh
payment cards and so on and so forth so
very very diverse region
that actually needs a lot of different
recipes if you will to kind of be
quoted with cracks for a business right
so that was my role when i joined google
right so we were actually very well
established here in the uae
but we didn't have a very very
meaningful footprint in the rest of the
region right so
when i when i started doing my uh
regional uh regional head of new markets
uh when i started where that had
basically my uh
my assignment was essentially to kind of
bring everything that we were able to
build here in the uae
and to kind of take it further out into
the rest of the region and
that i mean at the end you have you have
the responsibility of looking at both of
the emerging markets but also the
developed markets
and playing all these different hacks
right because for every
every region it's not just about the the
penetration of the technology but it's
also about the culture
and it's about how much do they trust
payment system how much do they trust
digital e-commerce
uh right and there's a lot of different
subtleties that you really have to take
into account yeah i mean
even to the extent i think corporate is
kind of interesting we're probably going
to talk about that a little bit but
even in terms of like how you do
business right right uh
like you know some parts of the region
some parts of uh
some countries in the region for them
the working culture is much more
face-face oriented right there is no way
for you to do business unless
you have kind of first established a
relationship unless you have actually
gone and smoked shisha with someone
unless you have gone and kind of had
coffee with them yeah yeah
and so on and so forth right so a lot of
times we think about the way that we do
business and kind of develop countries
that we're like well you know we're
going in an efficient way we'll just
jump on a call and kind of get things
done
well that's not typically how things
work in a lot of other countries in the
region and you kind of need to
be sensitive to all of these nuances if
you want to actually be successful 100
you know i'm i'm used to a fast-paced
model you know in some places
if i'm getting 15 minutes with somebody
from andreas and horowitz i'm lucky
and i have those first three minutes to
make the impression here one of the
first things they told me when i came to
dubai they said
michael before you mention anything that
has to do with technology with
investments whatever
sit down have a chat have coffee invest
the time in the relationship
otherwise nobody wants to do business
and it's a very different mentality
do most people fail that or do most
people understand and make that quick
adaptation because the world is getting
globalized right
right now it still feels a little bit
fragmented just by the shock factor that
i've
exhibited coming here yeah but if i'm am
i looking five ten years
even with the normalization with israel
things are going to become more
connected
so how do you expect people are going to
adapt this more business mindset between
two science yes so dubai is great i
think in in this regard and again i
don't know how
uh how well known that is outside of
kind of this uh uh
this more narrow region but dubai is
like a true melting pot
right it's like 190 nationalities if you
think about the population
uh uh segmentation if you will
uh again i don't know how many people
know that but out of three million
people in dubai
less than ten percent are the uae
nationals ten percent less than ten
percent of ua nationals
wow so if you think about it the
likelihood of you actually
uh you know bumping into somebody who's
kind of from another country
is like nine out of ten and in all
likelihood they're going to be from the
subcontinent they're going to be from
southeast asia they're going to be from
europe from the uk
less so from the u.s and latin america
just kind of from from a geographic
business point of view
but i think the fact that it's a melting
pot actually kind of gives rise to
this kind of uh being kind of attuned if
you will right and kind of more
sensitive to the fact that a person you
know
sitting across from you kind of at the
uh in a business meeting
is not going to be like you kind of from
a cultural point of view right so you
may not necessarily
understand their culture but you're
going to be naturally more attuned to
kind of understand that it's different
from yours right
and to kind of give them a benefit of
the doubt not necessarily jump to
conclusions
kind of get out of your way kind of
trying to basically kind of get uh
get to learn a little bit more about you
know how to be effective how to
establish those relationships how to
build them how to uh how to gain results
right
at the end of the day how do you explain
what we're seeing here how does it
happen
as soon as i get to dubai i'm seeing
these crazy towers
people seem to be very happy very low
crime rate
you know what's happening here what why
why is dubai this crazy melting pot
and why do we have this well i think the
the dubai the whole story of dubai is
really about
uh and you know the way to think about
dubai is
not even related to to to to the mena
region right it's the way to think about
it is kind of the headquarters of the
hub if you will
of a very very broad region which
actually comprises almost two billion
people
right and the way that they kind of set
up and actually kind of started from the
logistics so
uh before dubai was what it was in 1971
they built what is to become one of the
largest ports in the world which is dp
world in jabali which is like 20 miles
down the road right
and at that time there was literally
nothing i mean the dubai was more like a
efficient village with like 50
000 people right but there was a vision
to say that from a geographic point of
view
it is a hub that is kind of logistically
and
distance wise uh within a seven to eight
eight eight hour flight radius to more
than ten but up to more than two billion
people wow
so it's a good place to put a port in
right and it turned out to be the case
it's a good place to actually put an
airport in like an international airport
and today dubai international airport is
actually the largest international
airport in the world right actually
you've probably heard about the
emergency alliance it's one it's the
biggest international airline in the
world right in terms of like the number
of connections in terms of number people
they're kind of transporting hubbing
uh back and forth so think of dubai as a
hub right so
if you then think about that broader
region that dubai the dubai covers as a
hub
uh you have places like india you have
places like saudi arabia
places like iran you have places like
you know southeastern
south and east eastern europe even the
cis countries right all kind of somewhat
naturally gravitated towards a place
that has established itself as not only
a logistics hub
but also a hub that is very convenient
and very
safe to do business in right from kind
of a safety and security perspective but
also kind of from a regulations
perspective because they put in a lot of
kind of
a very solid regulatory framework around
you know just kind of allowing you to do
business with the rest of the region
so you have a place of 3 million people
90 percent of them are not even local
and it's become the hub of a region that
that encompasses two billion people
that's right
that's just unbelievable i i don't think
that neither myself nor many of my
friends that have actually are actually
understanding what's happening here
what's going to happen in the future if
you look at this if you look at this
whole region
mena the world with dubai as a hub
what's going to happen 20 years down the
line because the world is becoming more
and more globalized
i'm just experiencing it now because my
the two nations are normalized right
but what's going to happen in the future
do you think well it's anyone's guess
right at the end of the day but
uh i think the vision again we're
talking about the pre-kobe world i think
it rains remains to be seen what kind of
revenge is that the core we're going to
throw into
uh everything is happening but uh the
whole
underlying idea is that probably like
you know from this kind of a ground
vision perspective
we're probably not even like 30 percent
there really so
you know again like the emerging markets
are the ones that are kind of up and
coming right
and we can provide them with talent
technology
uh uh financial and regulatory framework
right what london
and new york are for the rest of the
world dubai as far as to be for this
kind of
uh part of the world in between hong
kong and london right so
all of these things i think they've just
crashed the surface off if you think
about what is happening in africa for
example right which is projected to have
more than one one and a half billion
people right
all kind of emerging from poverty and at
some point if that econ these economies
kind of
start picking up dubai is perfectly
positioned to actually kind of leverage
and kind of
profit off of that so i think that the
division still stands again you know
corbett and financial crisis they're
kind of throwing a couple of wrenches
but if you think about the macro trends
and if those macro trends continue
i think dubai is very well positioned to
uh to benefit from that that's
fascinating i know that you have to go
to to have a hard stop soon but but i
have to understand a little bit about
about the
tech ecosystem with investment so right
now you're leading the
chief development officer uh part of stb
saudi
group technology of interest study
technology ventures you're investing all
across the middle east and north africa
give me a little bit of an overview
because i know silicon valley pretty
well i know the united states and i know
tel aviv i don't know this region
what's happening here in terms of
technology and how does it fare
in comparison to more of the western
world and what's happening there yeah
so listen uh the the the the market here
kind of from a starter point of view is
super nascent
super nice right so i'll give you uh
just one way to think about it right
uh in terms of the in terms of the
overall amounts of venture funding
right u.s probably stands at around 100
billion give or take right per year
uh places like india are at around 10 to
12 billion give or take a year right
we are probably hitting our one billion
mark
uh over this year all right so kind of
from an order of magnitude perspective
it's still super small and very very
nice and there are a number of reasons
for that i think one of the big reasons
for that is that
the economies here uh historically were
uh essentially driven by large
organizations right by the extraction of
hydrocarbons obviously you know one of
the large companies in the world saudi
aranco is kind of the
the the oil company that transformed
from the ground and so on and so forth
a lot of things here also kind of from
an economic point of view are driven by
trade which is dominated by
by the large family offices and
conglomerates and all that so if you
think about
sme or kind this whole kind of sentiment
around
starting from the ground up and having
this kind of entrepreneurial mindset if
you weren't kind of making it big in the
world
it wasn't necessarily you know it wasn't
necessarily present best year right
the regulations were not supporting it
either the culture was not supporting
either you know we kind of take for
granted this whole kind of you know
start feel fast but then kind of you
know where what where the scars of that
failure is kind of a
a learning experience and kind of
something something not something you're
proud of right
here in this region feel it was
associated there's kind of a negative
connotation
to it right so from a cultural point of
view regulatory poor new economic point
of view it wasn't a place where
you know startups already kind of the
emerging kind of ecosystem
economy would thrive uh all of this is
changing and all of this is changing
super super fast right so again i've
told you about the
one billion dollar mark in in venture
funding
but it's actually kind of on the back of
50 million that was invested only five
years ago
so right so it's literally kind of been
it's getting kind of
exponential exponential growth
incredible and the reason for me to
actually move from google to a place
like sdv
like with all kind of the the uh the
branding differences and obviously kind
of
the the safety and then and and all the
other differences
is kind of looking at that uh
opportunity as a super nation
opportunity right yeah especially was
telling myself was you know do i want to
be there not only to witness it
but potentially participate in it enable
it and the clear answer was yes
all right and basically i told myself i
was probably too late
to do that in the silicon valley back in
2006 but i think i'm probably not too
late here because it's just starting and
i wanted to i wanted to kind of make a
good use of that see the exponential
curve exactly
yvonne i know we have to go i i this is
a i'm keeping you
very late but thank you so so much for
joining me on the show it's it's really
wonderful and i'm so excited to share
this with my friends with my family and
and i already learned so much even
before we leave to ask you the most
difficult question which i didn't
prepare you for so i'm sorry
but i need three words that you would
use to describe yourself or anybody at
stv
or in or in the mena region would
describe ivan as
interesting um
yeah i'm a father of three uh three boys
uh that i'm very proud of you wanted two
and a half so one of them
i wanted two and a half i really wasn't
sure where if i'm going to end up on
on one side or the uh uh or the other
uh i think the second one is
passionate passionate about helping
people passionate about
educating people passionate about
growing people
uh and the third one would be
again it's kind of related to the first
one but it's family really
uh and not only my my media family but
also my brother family as well so i love
it
thank you so much elbow bump really high
to everyone that
stanford for me please we'll do it thank
you